President Trump called Russian President
Vladimir Putin to offer his condolences
after a deadly attack on a st.
Petersburg subway train a suspected
suicide bomber killed at least 14 people
Elizabeth Palmer's near the scene of the
attack in st. Petersburg with new
details on the attacker Elizabeth good
morning good morning he's actually been
named
now he's Akbar Jean Jaleel off and he
was named by the security services of a
small Republic called Kyrgyzstan it lies
south of Russia near the Afghan border
and that's where Julie love was born in
1995 the bomb powerful enough to blow
out the doors of the train actually went
off between stations but the driver
managed to reach the next stop they're
shocked passengers groping through the
smoke and chaos helped those who
couldn't help themselves the bomb had
been filled with shrapnel to cause
maximum carnage saint-petersburg subway
system was immediately shut down as
rescue workers rushed the injured up to
street level and into ambulances at a
nearby station police found and defused
a second bomb they think was hidden by
the same bomber Russian media reported
was disguised as a fire extinguisher
President Putin who comes from st.
Petersburg last night came to lay
flowers near the scene of the attack
though so far he's only said
investigators are following all leads
this isn't the first time Russian
Subway's have been attacked most
recently in Moscow two woman's suicide
bombers killed at least 40 people in
2010 but that was linked to the war
since ended against Islamic nationalists
in the Russian Republic of Chechnya
since then Russia has joined Syria's
messy Civil War and Isis has more than
once threatened revenge
now that Isis connection is one that
investigators are going to be pursuing
very vigorously today as well as the
distinct possibility that he was another
one of these self radicalized lone
wolves Charlie there's no Palmer in st.
Petersburg thanks Liz